yeah I don't know that much about
gymnastics my goal today to do it
currently I've never been able to do a
cartwheel
okay follow a lot it was a trampoline so
I'm looking forward to that too
hi welcome to Broadway gymnastics I'm
coach Cara and we have a group of
beginning students here and we're gonna
get them out of their comfort zones and
have a good time
look at that I think we all forgot that
Nick is a sidewalk finally accomplished
my high school fears of climbing a rope
oh yeah so we just wound up apparently
and I don't think I could do anymore
touch it hand on the floor big push I
have this fear that I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna roll and my head's gonna snap
off of my body
like a rainbow
dr. Chynn I found your mouth I'll stand
up State I just try to turn your body on
your toes I don't know what I'm supposed
to do nope nope nope
yeah nope nope this is another time
I want to save my energy for the
trampoline I know there's going to be
addressed I'm not going to waste my time
on these log walking whatever the great
thing about a gym like this is there's a
bed everywhere anywhere you want to go
and then they have a bed for you today I
didn't accidentally kill myself or
anybody else and I call that a success I
conquered a lot of my fears today I feel
like Superman once I let go of the fear
of breaking my neck I actually could do
some famous elf everything's true Bleen
I know it's like not
her but that ball so high got that's so
fun
I'm on his family my joints are all
broken like crawl my way to my car she
said that swing is not encouraged but
it's fun